foundations of quantum mechanics or
foundations but that's the standard for
foundations of quantum mechanics
infamously when you go to a Physics
course if you get a Physics degree and
you ask about well what does this
so-and-so mean especially when it comes
to Quantum field Theory quantum
mechanics they say hey go to a
philosophy Department essentially what
I'm asking is what textbooks should one
read let's say they're at The Graduate
level in order to become familiar with
Quantum foundations like is there a set
of five books that you feel like hey
read these in this order that gives you
a great introduction well I mean the
thing I I was once did a did a thing at
the end they ask you name five books in
your field that you would recommend
and I said and I was only half joking I
would say I I said okay get this book
and read it five times okay that I mean
I mean you know this is a collection of
Articles and there are different levels
and it's not a single presentation but
Belle is really On Target really really
beautifully out there and you have to be
careful when you read him because he's
he's so precise in the way he writes
that he'll say something once and he
won't beat you over the head with it a
hundred times and you have to pay
attention I beat people over the head
right my technique as I say is to use a
two by four and whack you over the head
a hundred times and say the same thing
um Bells using a scalpel and sort of
just like that it's like direct yeah I
mean it's just I mean it's beautiful and
he's really again if you're worried
about super determinism just read this
four-page paper Bells it's all there
um so you should read that if you're if
you're used to a physics if you're a
physics major and you're used to a
physics presentation there's this nice
book by Travis Morrison that came out I
don't know five years ago
um
I think it's called foundations of
quantum mechanics but it's really for
physics students
as an introduction to
quantum theory but with attention to the
historical and historical background and
conceptual detail that's not in a normal
physics book
and it goes over interpretations as well
yeah
um then you know David Albert who people
may not know got his degree in
theoretical physics from Rockefeller
University but was interested in
foundations and therefore switched to a
philosophy department so he's in the
philosophy Department of Colombia you
know he wrote a book which is more
philosophical and a little more out
there in certain ways called quantum
mechanics and experience
and it's not you know it it's not like
norson's book which is aimed at physics
students it's it's aimed I mean David's
trying to take as much math out of it
as possible
um and kind of look at the conceptual
issues
um I mean you have my book which is
philosophy of physics quantum theory
which is you know it's more math than
David has and less math than Travis has
all right it's in between the two and
every one of the books you mentioned for
those who are watching that'll be in the
description
um I I I think you know between those
four books
you certainly have everything you need
um
and the book by you what was it called
philosophy of physics colon quantum
theory there's a little set of of books
it's a it's a series of books that are
supposed to be introductory books for
philosophers to different issues and I
did the philosophy of physics one but
there are two volumes one is space and
time which is an introduction to
space-time Theory and relativity and the
other is quantum theory which is about
Quantum Theory and someday I'm going to
do a third part or put them all together
and do something on statistical
explanation and thermodynamics and
entropy and stuff but that's somewhere
in the future
what the heck is a Bible a b able be
able yeah so what the heck is a biable
and why did Bell invent this terminology
because to me as an outsider it just
sounds like something that exists some
ontological object that's all it is but
that's you see
the word ontology and I can testify from
personal experience it scares physicists
right you say what's the ontology of
their Theory and they go like ontology
okay because they didn't learn Greek
right
um an ontology just means in Greek Anta
are the things that exist and logos is
an account so the ontology of your
theory is tell me what your theory
postulates to exist
and Bell wanted a word for the same
thing now he could have used ontology
but he didn't I don't know why
um I mean he doesn't have a philosophy
background maybe it didn't occur to him
and he even says in a paper he says in
the theory of local people's he said
well he yeah he wanted a word
whose root was to be or to exist as
opposed to observable I mean what he was
doing was setting a contrast with the
term observable
because so many physicists would say oh
physics is about observables observables
observables and Bell said no no
it should be about be a bulls things
that exist
I mean he said he considered be ER
b-e hyphen ER but then that looks like
deer right and then he he he on the
model of observable he put be able
um it's you know I would just call it
the ontology of the theory but for
phosphorus would just call it the
ontology of the theory and physicists
should just get used to it's you know
it's but you can call it the Bibles it's
fine because Bell use that
um
it's just what what is your physical
Theory
postulate to physically exist now this
is a question which would be the first
question it's not a philosophical
question
it's not oh philosophers are interested
in that no physicists right that's the
founding that's what your physics is
actually postulating to physically exist
right it's the first question you should
ask of any physical theory if you want
to understand it what does it postulate
to actually exist and unfortunately
because foundations of physics does not
is not part of a standard physics
education
which it isn't
um physicists get very nervous around
questions like this and sometimes they
they suggest answers that don't kind of
make any sense so there's a physicist
who I will Who Remain unnamed who has
asked this question at one of our
conferences well what's the you know
what are the beibles of your theory what
does your theory postulate and came up
with the answer matrices
and you want to say no no that's not
even in the right ballpark right a
matrix is a mathematical object okay in
a matrix is a set of numbers in an array
you're not going to tell me the world
the physical world is made up of sets of
numbers in an array well if your max
tegmark well yeah I mean yes yes
take Mark exactly okay I mean you can
talk about and this is a real confusion
to me I mean it makes when when Max goes
way out and says
the world just
has a mathematical reality and the the
physical world has no reality that's any
different than any other mathematical
object you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy